today I'm gonna talk about basically a
caching framework that I developed over
the past year for buting
production-ready cache and the name is
polycon I came up with this name like
three days ago so and renamed my entire
repo after it so it's all good so a
little bit about me I have been working
at Twitter since 2010 back when the
day's Twitter was still cool and back
web when you know the fail whale was to
do a thing and this whole time you know
twice the average job duration in the
Silicon Valley five almost five years
I've been working on cash so I've done a
lot pretty much everything you can think
of about cash including testing capacity
planning you know debugging weird
performance issues arguing with
customers how they abused cash and
recently I have to become interim
manager of the cash team so literally
every job on the team I've done so a
little bit about this talk you will find
that this is a talk that's mostly not
about cash because what is there to talk
about you have a key value store you
stick a key in it may or may not be
there you know you will know soon enough
right so so so there's not much to talk
about cash but but that doesn't mean we
are cruising along right it's it's not
like the the job of the cash team is
just to drink coffee and read tacker
news every day we still spend way too
much time dealing with all kinds of
issues so we're gonna do something about
it so but those things and they're
mostly not about cash and of course all
my experience actually this job it's my
first full-time job after grad school so
all my exposure to cash is somewhat
bonded and limited by what Twitter
exposed me to so that sort of sets the
boundary so if you have InfiniBand I
cannot help you you're in a much better
place than I do so so I would tell a
little bit about what Twitter's use
cases are and and sort of sets the stage
and I would see I personally see it as a
quest for high quality infrastructure
one thing that upsets me a lot is people
keep using the same
really fundamental infrastructure pieces
for a long time but some of the
fundamental problems never gets
addressed so if I get a chance to do
whatever I want which sort of is my
current position now I want to do
something about it right so this is a an
attempt to view high quality
infrastructure whether that's that's
successful not I think only time can
tell all right so let's set the context
context is king marketing people tell
you all the time
so first let's say look at a Twitter's
basically deployment scale we deploy
cash as many clusters actually we have
over 200 clusters in production so
usually if someone has a new use case
they come to us we'll give them a new
cluster instead of sort of the face book
model where they have a very very fat
cache over a very very fat database so
we instead of sort of trying to do
resource isolation withing a single
instance we what we do is we try to
deploy all these clusters with little
overhead so even if we do a lot we don't
introduce too much overhead and we use
containers and we try to automate the
deploy because nobody wants to manually
come up with you know how to configure
200 caches so we basically take a
different approach from many other big
companies or even bigger companies in
the industry I don't think there's a
definitive answer for which one is
better you can make either way work you
just have to put effort into different
areas and our QPS varies greatly our
smallest clusters only have like tens of
thousands of QPS we constantly ask them
why are you on cash but usually they
want to stay so on you know power to
them and our biggest use cases usually
have tens of millions of QPS out of a
single cluster so you have this three
four orders of magnitude differences
between the largest ones and the
smallest ones so that's a pretty big
range and in terms of data models we
have a lot of variety to people
sometimes use it just to store blobs
sometimes people will store counters and
there are people who store you know the
the signature twitter service would be
timelines and timelines essentially are
stored as indices so it's just a list of
numbers and there are of course the the
and hottest real-time data analysis
those are dealing with time series so
time serious actually a twitter uses
hash kavanah to to get a view temporary
view of some of the the big time series
they degenerate so all of these data
models yield very different query sizes
you can imagine reading a time series
would be a lot of data but a condor will
be only a few bytes and the read and
write pattern are pretty mixed so we
have read dominant cases where for
example tweets would be dominant who
generated tweet wants you after that you
only read it and there will be write
dominant cases where liked timelines
it's this write dominant because you fan
out to everybody's time line so they add
the index but they only read it very
every once in a while so it's very hard
for us to say we are going to just
optimize for re having your workload or
optimize for right heavy workload
optimized for a particular data model or
optimize for you know a particular query
size because they're all over the map so
cache is basically a soft problem
memcache D is 12 years old even Redis
the the new incoming is also already six
years old and we use both of them not
only that we have even more solutions we
have slim cache which is the cache
specialized for tiny tiny objects and we
have fat cache which is you know if you
want to put things on SSD you can use
fat cache so not only is it a soft
problem it's a problem that has been
solved multiple times repeatedly and we
use all of these solutions and and
structurally it's really simple you can
as you can see a request comes in coming
in to the bottom you know you gets
through asynchronous IO gets into the
buffer you're going to parse the
requests and if later on you will
compose the response and you're gonna
process and essentially all your
processing is just go into this memories
in memory store somewhere and you sort
of plug the data out of it if it's not
there you just tell user to that right
so so so there's there's conceptually
there's very little complexity in this
thing but it that doesn't mean we're
down with a cache
so the first thing I want to point out
that we have more than one things on the
left-hand side that's a problem so if
cash is conceptually so simple it's
trying to solve this one problem why do
we have so many solutions and the short
answer to that is none of these
solutions actually provide everything we
need
memcache D it doesn't support data
structure for some people that's not
acceptable Redis Redis manages memory
basically well radius basically doesn't
rent manage memory it allocates that to
je malloc so you will have external
fermentation and your malloc performance
is gonna be somewhat unpredictable if
your workload is mixed right and and and
so and so forth but also if you have a
team of a few people and and the team of
people is supposed to maintain all these
code bases it's totally not
unsustainable if there is a problem
that's common to one of the if there's a
common problem you have to fix it four
times and that's that's just ridiculous
and also there are a few challenges that
I think today still largely applies to
most people using cash but it shows more
when your scale is large and these
problems are not really well addressed
by any of the existing solutions first
of all there's just too many ways to
fall below lastly SOA is usually defined
by how many QPS can you sustain and
what's your tale they didn't see let's
say your p triple nine agency and very
few cashes out there can say under such
and such conditions I will be able to
very steadily generators to keep es
under this latency profile and I will
not fail that right so so there's
unpredictability in the tail latency
part and and small things can slow down
for example we had to turn down our log
level from info to warning because we
realized that occasionally the the
belonging is slowed down the entire
cache because there's some other janky
process running in the background that
hurts the disk every once in a while so
if you try to access the disk through
logging they during those time window
for mysterious reasons the entire
process just slows down right so so so
there are other things like you know
networking stack
sad things we cannot predict and those
all can make cash flow below SLA and and
when cash falls below SLA it has this
ripple effect all throughout the stack
and the second thing is like any
stateful services cash is very prone to
hotkeys and DDoS attacks hotkeys usually
comes from you know like Lady Gaga
tweets something or like the Oscar
incident of twitter is a very good
example basically Allen summons the
entire internet to attack one server
inside Twitter right and then she was
very very successful and we were done
and we had to sort of repair our
architecture to handle that kind of
hotkey for months and still today there
is no good way of handling haki so what
do you do when the cache is receiving
too much traffic the only solution we
have is that IT Crowd quote have you
tried to turn off and turn on the cache
that's literally it we that's the only
knob we have and that's pathetic
right so so so what are the better knobs
better knobs include I can reject the
excessive requests but I can serve the
rest I can apply back pressure I can
tell my caller stop calling me or
calling me last frequently and use
whatever stale copy you have for a
little bit so I can't breathe right but
if you look at today's memcache tree
protocol Redis protocol back pressure is
not actually part of the design so so
there's no place you can have these
additional features of pressure
protection into existing architecture
and also it's really hard to debug
I had a few bugs I had to solve two bugs
in production through pure guessing like
twice because I couldn't turn on logging
if I turn a logging we had that problem
and in the first case right you know the
full whole thing basically doesn't work
so so I basically had to guess because
I've been working on this for many years
I have good guesses and I reproduce it
locally by altering like sometimes
monitoring malikan enforcing certain
behavior to show up and then I deliver
with high confidence that this is going
to fix it and and and of course
eventually they fix
but in one case it took me three weeks
in another case it took me a week it's
just way too long there's not enough
tools out there or information out there
for me to debug and if essentially
eventually there's also kepada capacity
planning problems external fragmentation
is terrible
like if you have to do deal with a
capacity plan you you know what I'm
talking about so if you think you are
using one gig of heat your internal
metrics track that you are using one gig
of heat however somehow you have a
fragmentation ratio of 1.3 meaning
you're using 1.3 gigabytes
how do you plan for capacity do you
assume everybody's gonna use 30% next
year what if they use 50% actually
what's in your control and another
source of surprise capacity is its
connections right most services would
just accept connections as they come in
and they don't really have a cap for it
this is true for memcache that's true
for Redis so what if you have a network
glitch now all your connections are lost
for the client of course your client
would try to reach it's flat establish
those connections but the resources
attached to the previous connections
don't necessarily go away maybe not even
for a long time unless you set your
keepalive correctly all right so so
suddenly you have a lot more additional
resources that you are holding up and in
this case too bad that you run in
containers right unless you have lots of
headroom if you're running container you
you reserve 1.5 gigs thinking you have
give it 50 percent overhead and somehow
you mysterious it goes over that
threshold magic threshold your entire
job is killed and this is terrible for
stateful services which caches wanna
because if there's a global condition
that triggers this 50% overhead to every
other backhand back and you can lose
your entire state and at that point I
guarantee you Twitter is gonna go down
right so all these things we don't have
we sort of cope and hope that they don't
show up too often but when they show up
we are were eventually essentially you
know defenseless so here's a basically
you will come to the drawing table and
say what do we want so we essentially
one code base that supports or our use
cases it's just cash let's do cash right
just just a simple thing and I want it
to be easy and fun to work on I want to
reduce time that I read the code and I
want to curse because that's not how you
do sustainable projects it eventually I
won't really want the cash to be
production ready
meaning that when we deploy there to two
hundred two hundred clusters I don't
have to worry about the Hong Kong not
getting any sleep for the next week but
here's the problem
what is production readiness I don't
think anybody know so so by here I said
we but I don't want to include everybody
I'm sure there are good engineers out
there who knows way more than I do but
first of all we includes I I took this
job five years ago I was supposed to
keep Twitter's cash up I had not viewed
anything in production ever so of course
I brought the site down multiple times
right you know it's sort of my I wear it
as my badge of honor but but but truth
is I had no idea and I had to learn a
lot of things one one example is Locker
rotation in grass when nobody told me I
would I was supposed to pay attention to
lock rotation and of course I knew
nothing about it and four months after I
deploy my system like where's my desk
and then I realize I have to redeploy
all my services host [ __ ] ton of data
just because I didn't put large rotation
in place and it wasn't correctly
configured so I felt plenty bad about it
but I made sure I didn't make that
mistake ever again but certain enough
all the projects around me some other
hashed projects mesas Manhattan which is
Twitter's storage projects every single
one of them when they went into
production
they had rotation issues nobody knew how
to set them correctly the first time
so so that's I mean this is still a
small scale it could be that all the
infrastructure people at Twitter are you
know it's just somehow incompetent but
but I suspect it's there's something to
it right the industry is so young
everybody it's working with something
new you just don't know right so so I'm
like ok let's let's google it and see if
there's a production readiness
that I can just check and copy and make
sure I do better and and actually I
found nothing
so so there's no information guiding
anybody's to say if you do these things
you have a good chance to have a stable
system that serves you well in
production that list doesn't exist so
instead we do we go to big companies
companies bigger than us or of a similar
size and say what do you use I use
whatever you use because I trust you
would have solved all these problems
which works most of the time but there
are two problems first is there's no
guarantee that they have solved those
problems they might be faking in who
knows and they may have very different
infrastructure they may have different
setups they may have a different set of
rule for referral tools that secretly
cleans out all the logs that you you
just don't have so if you use their
solution without their context it
doesn't it may or may not work for you
right and also it's it's sort of a we
put a lot of faith just because
someone's big or someone is important in
the industry and that's a little bit
unfair to the product yourself the
second attitude is just bucket you know
you hope for the best you just deploy
and you hold tight to your on call phone
if something buzzes then you know you're
just gonna dick done and try to solve it
so I'm like I've done this enough times
I want to define at my best
what is production ready cash so I want
to hold this standard against myself I
want to hold this against any cash I
will use in the future and see if they
provide everything that I need so it
comes with a few things so first of all
is pretty predictable so the bigger your
scale the more important predictability
is if you have one instance one use case
chances are it's gonna be fine that's
exactly what happens when you try to use
something on your laptop but if you use
200 clusters and they they're all over
the map then weird things are bound to
happen so if something is so-so
something in your workflow it's going to
trigger unpredictability if those are in
place so we really want very stable
tendencies and we want predictable
performances
because these will also allow you to
automate your capacity planning the
second thing is failure behavior so once
we get a Twitter because we operated a
certain scale it's actually really easy
to DDoS the cache I I have this we have
this incident where we would see a big
spike of writes when when something gets
a little slower and when we talk to the
customer they're like oh yeah when we
don't get our data we would just assume
the data is not there and we were just
gonna try to add the data back into
cache which is perfectly reasonable
however if you think about it if you get
a write that is a Miss sorry if you get
a read that is a Miss and you get a read
that is an exception these actually
indicate whole or different things right
and exception means you know the network
is down it doesn't indicate anything
about the actual existing of the data in
the cache so only when you have a true
read miss should you try to answer the
data into the cache in other cases
you're just contributing to a problem
that's probably already slowing the
cache stuff right so so when these kind
of things happens the back and usually
behaves badly when you see too many
requests it just drops everything on the
floor and now client starts the D
connecting and reconnecting and those
create what we call sync storms so you
have a lot of clients trying to
establish clash into a single server at
the same time it's actually a very very
expensive operation in the case of cache
it's much more expensive than issuing
your requests so basically from there
you have a snowballing effect where
things go goes from bad to worse alright
so these are not what we call graceful
degradation you want something to
protect yourself do as much work as it
can and sort of share the rest of the
load off and if eventually you know
there's a resource footprint like I said
before you don't want someone claimed
they are using one gigabytes of memory
but actually uses two and gets killed by
same asos in the meantime so
observability everything in production
should be ready for monitoring it's it's
so obvious into the day before lunch
right you're like I'm gonna write my
alerts if something
goes bad I'm gonna be called up about it
but oh wait a second I don't have any
metrics in my system so this is not
uncommon it's not as dramatic but most
people would basically push off
observability and to the last second and
two they have to go through some
production readiness meeting and someone
asked them a question do you have stats
and then they spend two hours adding
metrics to their system but they will
see later that this is not the best way
you can do it and debug ability is it's
really important so so cash has been
around for long enough that people would
sort of just wave it off be like this
cash have bait has been used for a
decade
it must be bulletproof but this
mentality doesn't work anymore if you
want to create something new which I
think every engineer wants to do right
so people gets very afraid when they
cannot debug their system because any
new logic introduced is very hard to
debug and there's no guarantee those are
gonna be right so lack of deductibility
basically slows you down or even stops
you from making changes and and another
thing I think it's very nice to have is
when I first started working on cash I
spent about two weeks reading memcache
code base which was not pleasant so I
spent a lot of time figuring out what
the logic flow of the system is which is
a problem for everybody who's coming
into a new code base so one thing about
visibility that's nice would be if you
can come to a system issue a typical
operation and you can see all the key
components telling you what they're
doing you sort of have the flow of a key
action in a new system that helps you
greatly sort of bootstrapping yourself
and familiarize yourself with with the
code base okay so and eventually I think
this has been sort of a little bit of
step up from the rest which is fairly
standard is in the analytics friendly
who here who has operated cash can tell
me with confidence that if you want to
achieve a 90% hit rate how much memory
should you provide for your particular
use case for 85 or 95 do you know how
much cap and data in your cash is in
cacheable that they only read once and
never read again
right so so so if you if you you know do
as much planning as we do our customers
ask this question all the time and
usually what we say oh you should know
about your data right we're just you're
just providing infrastructure we're not
supposed to know but but this is not
impossible we you can look at the
traffic pattern someone's trying to read
someone's trying to write you can look
at those accesses and over time you
should be able to construct a map how
many times that he has been accessed
since its created right these things
information actually are accessible
within cache if we can find a way of
sort of directing them out and to the
right analysis infrastructure then you
can actually have a optimal
configuration so finally we want things
to be flexible you know and everything
that can be configured that's
configurable should be exposed if you
cannot solve your specific use cases by
configuring with the right tuning knobs
you should be able to do small
modifications on the source code
proportional to the change that you want
to introduce instead of forking the repo
and and doing this thing all together
and losing all the upstream benefits and
I wanted something that's quick to
develop features because of course
customers don't come and talk to you
several months before they launch they
all they'll always come to you a month
before and be like we need this
otherwise you're slowing us down you're
delaying our launched it you do not want
to be that person so we want things to
to be easy and quick and and in fact if
you do it correctly if future
development is about the easiest thing
like I the last three features that
develops and none of them took me more
than a day right so so if most of the
time it's about refactoring other things
and and one thing I want to point out is
all these attributes are sort of related
you you want your observability to be
flexible you want to be able to turn off
up observability if you want to even
just to test how expensive observe it
yes like what's the overhead of it and
you want your predictably to be
observable because you want to know
what's your true latency instead of
you're just assuming right soso so these
things are concepts are not sort of ISIL
in isolation you cannot just bolt
something
on to your final product and claim you
have achieved one of them they basically
these should be carried out throughout
the development process okay so I've
talked about of you know grand ideas
what have we done how do we measure
against all those things that we think
we want to achieve well I assure you
there's a lot of boxes here don't worry
you don't have to read you don't have to
read you know each one of them I think
the thing I want to call out is you can
see there are two parts right that the
top part it says cash the bottom part
assess common core so these are actually
intentional divide I'll explain them
later the the dotted line means
components that we actually still need a
lot of work on and the solid ones are
things that are fairly usable so so one
of the takeaway from the previous chart
is there are lots of boxes that means
we're doing a lot of work to properly
and formally modularize all the
functionalities that we see and it's
actually the trickiest part of coming up
with this thing is sort of coming up
with those modules and and scoping them
correctly because if you do too little
marginalization everything is just in a
big blob it's just a magnet for
attracting technical debt right it's
very unwieldy it's a monolithic it's
actually sort of the state of previous
caches because they were exactly solving
one problem so so they just sort of put
everything together over time and that
proves a little difficult to evolve but
if you do too much of that you end up
with like a Scala program you click and
click and click every class adds an
additional attribute and five times
later you finally know what's in an
object so there's a sum sum of a balance
between there and and and you really
want to minimize surface area if you
don't need to expose something don't
expose that because if you want to
change it behind this thing later you
will require that you have expose it in
the first place because someone might be
misusing it now so of all each module
you basically ask you those questions is
it observable is a configurable is a
flexible those things you make that
thought process
done at the module level not the
application level so when you put them
together it's easy because every one of
those modules is ready to go so one
thing I want to call out is code we use
I think Cobre use is definitely
overrated being a lot of projects often
what we do is we look at what we already
have on all the building blocks and we
view things on top of it the problem was
that is those might not be perfect fit
so you might be cooking your design very
slightly just so that you could use
those beauty box right the building
block may not come with observability
you go with it now you have a black box
so so basically my priority has always
been structural integrity first and then
I will reuse as much code as I can but
I'm gonna order it if I have to see in a
sense is actually a good language for
that sort of philosophy because it's
really hard to reuse currency there's
there's no namespace you have to
actually copy the code you need to make
sure it compiles so you've got to change
it anyway right so so that's actually
helpful for us to sort of design from a
clean slate and then we will see what we
can use so and then we'll alter it and
and another sort of common pitfall is oh
I'm gonna write a framework and we're
gonna make sure this module works for
five different scenarios with you know
two different connection types you know
over generalization I try to build a
future-proof module that never works
unless you use the module in that way
you probably will come up with slightly
wrong abstractions so instead of doing
something that's future proof I think
the best we can do is to say let me
think about what the possible use cases
are let me just don't think don't do
things that outright would prevent me
from doing those things I may not be do
do those things in the future without
changing my code first but as long as
it's not like in the opposite direction
I'm just gonna go with whatever I need
to be right now so that's sort of the
minimum abstraction approaches what we
take
so finally we have a cup of core
decisions
those are splits the first one is the
one you saw we split our code bases
structurally into two parts the first
part is a common core the way of
thinking about the common core is what
if you want a pink server but instead of
your 200 line you know a quick
prototyping server you have a production
reading server you can deploy it through
your system at large scale you get all
the metrics you get all the logs
whatever you want but it's a ping server
so the the reason we did this is because
ping server is the mother of all servers
right anything that is a proper service
has to be able to handle ping it's
really well so we do ping server first
and we will add on all the cache related
parts on top of it so making this into
two problems then the second thing
decision we may was we want to
explicitly call out control plane and
data plane so there's a lot of
functionalities that are that are
extremely important but they tend to
slow things down like logging if you log
and you need to flush the log to disk
that potentially creates contention
point where IO could block the rest
right so so if you identify what
operations are on a data plan which
shouldn't be anything more than you know
reading from a socket or any other media
processing the request and writing a
response really your your data plan
should be extremely simple and then you
lump all the other necessary but not
performance critical functionalities on
to control plane and you want to have
physical separations of these two in
terms of runtime you want to have
dedicated thread to your data plane and
you want your data plan to never be
blocked and then you do the rest on the
on the control plane thread which you
know if something happens whatever right
so so having this mental model allows us
to to optimize our performance and to
get rid of a lot of the non determinism
on the data plane so the development is
mostly done by me starting from 2014
summer and this
here I was joined by another engineer
and we just got on someone else a third
person on the project so so we are well
stuffed right now and we did a claim
design so I didn't set out anything to
be reused but in the end we were able to
achieve about 50% code reuse so about
50% of the logic I copy paste it from
somewhere else like including from cache
shredders twin proxies some of them very
well tested code bases and we have three
binaries right now pala confirm cache
base it is a tomcat replacement which is
memcache D compatible polylines slim
cache which I'll talk about in a little
bit it's just a variety of memcache and
park and Redis right now it's sort of a
stealth so it's a Redis is a lot of work
we are not nearly done in that in a
space yet but eventually we will be able
to support a lot of the Redis protocol
out of the single codebase
and we have done some production deploy
you if you a regular Twitter user some
of the Condors you have seen on the
tweets are served out of slim cache but
we we factor the codebase significantly
since then so we're back to the joint a
back to the sort of the test lab we're
gonna do a load testing and then we're
gonna roll out again and replacing all
the existing meant memcache cases with
disco bass so okay let's put things to
the test so what have I done to make
this version more production ready than
the previous ones first is so the things
at the bottom of the of the overall
architecture chart I want to call these
out specifically because these are
special logging stats configs they sort
of go against the divide and conquer
overall methodology we apply to a
modular rise design because modular
writes design means other than the
interfaces exposed by those modules you
shouldn't care about anything behind it
right but observability is sort of
peeking into otherwise black box and get
some insight so so that means all these
functionalities they are not just
modules they are actually
bifidus their paradigms that you have to
apply everywhere so they have global
implications if logging is slow if stats
is slow if config is inconvenient it
affects every single model so it has to
be they have to be given priority
instead of bolting something on at the
last minute they actually have to come
in first so they have to be cheap
you don't want locks you don't want
anything that could block they should be
configurable so you can test with or
without them to know the performance
implications and all that things or if
you don't use a module you shouldn't pay
for the logging cost or the stats cost
or the memory right and eventually we
want to make them composable so if every
single module every single motor you you
ever write or encounter has
configurability and has monitoring and
has logging beaut into them you don't
have to write observability for them you
just have to include them and the
observability just happens so that's
very nice here's an example of what I
mean by those and because see is this is
where the age of C really shows you I
have to use some preprocessor magic to
achieve certain things so it's not
really all that pretty but but I guess
the job done so on top you have a bunch
of metrics for this particular model
which is buffer that you want to track
so you just declare them the type in the
explanation and there are two other
preprocessor macros help you helping you
to initialize them and declare them so
that's all you need to do for
declaration and initialization and when
you use them it's you know it's just
like any other within this the buffer
module you would try to increment the
right counter at the right place and if
I write a service that use this
particular module I can include the
metrics related to buffer along with all
the other modules that I used and I want
to observe and I will allocate memory
for them globally and when I initialize
the module which is at the bottom I was
set it up with the right memory location
for all the metrics this way I will any
if I set up my application this way
to get visibility into the buffer
mountain metrics there's nothing the
application needs to do extra to track
it the second thing I want to call out
is buffer Channel and stream these are
sort of i/o related components IO is is
so-so in cash actually you would see
majority of the resources being consumed
actually by doing IO and in doing IO
efficiently usually you have to resort
or asynchronous IO which is extremely
painful to handle right people don't
think about asynchronous programming
very naturally so it's nice to sort of
single out buffer as this barrier
between asynchronous programming and
synchronous programming cash has the
luxury that wants something isn't buffer
everything you need to do at that point
you know serialization processing is all
can all be done synchronously so so if
someone can write a cash-only thinking
from the same point of buffer is
actually not that hard and then you
delegate the rest you know to some
underlying framework the common core we
talked about and that will eventually
give you the data in the buffer and one
thing another thing I want to say is you
can see we say buffers channels and
streams in plural because there's
actually a lot of research that could go
into say channels you can have UDP you
can have TCP if you have have the luxury
of infinite band the the channel
interface can actually can use
dramatically different performance but
we haven't seen too much of that
experimentation in the existing
solutions because existing solutions
have the the channels like TCP very
tightly coupled with the rest of the
processing so if you want to change how
you handle channel you have to fork the
entire base there's no dropping channel
replacement so if you single out that
interface and you have a generic the
definition of what the channel should do
you can swap out you can have your UDP
amputation you can have UNIX to my
socket implementation and they use and
feel the same for the logic above them
so so that sort of encourages us at
least us in the future to explore some
of those possibilities one last thing is
sort of
the design principle is if you can have
a symmetrical design don't go with
something that's arbitrary in this case
you can see we sort of formalized the
the cash processing into these stages
right you you come in with a buffer
again a nice starting point for
synchronous programming you parse the
buffer you get a request you process
requests you get the response you
compose a response from the object and
now you end up having some data in your
write buffer and in the middle you may
need to consult some storage to get the
data this is very clear right so but if
you look at again the existing
implementations what they tend to do is
they tend to sort of compress processing
and composing together so so the entire
product or they sometimes have do a
little parsing in the processing stage
so so mentally it's very hard to to
decide when does one operation stop and
another operation and start so it makes
it just a little bit harder to write new
caches if you have to so in this case if
you want to write you know a usable
cache service the flow is exactly the
same you have you start with a read
event some data is coming so you read it
through i/o you'd now have data so you
need to do some processing and
processing is the three three stages we
stated which is parsing processing and
composing and now you have data that you
need to stand out you just go with a
largely symmetrical structure where you
start with the right event and the
infrastructure takes care of the rest so
if you want to write a new cache you
have awesome idea about a new protocol
that uses a new storage
you only need to alter the part in the
middle right so so the Audis also more
specifically you all you need to
implement is these five functions you
need how you need to know how to parse a
request and you don't know how to
compose a response and you don't know
how to process a request actually three
is the bare minimum right so if you were
doing a server you only need three but
having five provides symmetry allows you
to do testing allows you to write a
client so using the same library there
are nice things but basically that's it
you know writing a cache should be super
easy as that so as a case study I can
tell you what you know what we did
so to encash which we are going to
replace itself is 14,000 lines of code
it uses the verb and which I didn't
count Pelican tuam cash which is the new
thing is 16 thousand lines of code
including event libraries and the common
core ends up being the majority of the
code again proving the the the fact that
cash is not that complicated so in the
rest of the cash flow logic is seven
thousand lines of code so compared to a
stand-alone like everything squished
together implementation it's actually
not that bad it's only slightly larger
the benefit starts to show once you want
to add a new cash so we want to achieve
something really nice for the small
object like if you have a simple counter
with a simple key you are paying way
more overhead than the actual data
so both memcache and Redis spent about
60 bytes to store every single object so
if you have you know you have a condor
which is eight bytes and they have a key
again as eight bytes you were actually
spending majority 80% of the storage
space just storing overhead so we can
actually do much better using cuckoo
hashing um but that means we need to
swap out the the storage part so so we
did exactly that so and we we did
everything in under sixteen hundred
lines of code and about half of that
goes into implementing the new storage
we need to do new processing to use the
new storage paradigm and then we need to
set up because we need a second binary
we need to set up some other code to get
a new executable but the marginal cost
of adding cash and also I want to
mention this uses the memcache D
protocol so we didn't have to write that
part but the marginal cost of adding a
new cache now becomes much more
affordable compared to previously when
we have to fork that the code base and
litter our changes throughout the code
base so this is basically how slim
caches down there cuckoo caching I've
talked to people who have used
this book caching other scenarios before
if you have if you're curious feathers
and have insights you know come talk to
me afterwards so in summary we basically
spend almost a year achieving something
we already have nothing no new feature
has been added to through our code base
since we created it however now we have
great about the debug ability so I said
weightless logging and I mean weightless
logging we can't you can log however
much you want
it will never slow down the worker
thread because it never touches disk we
use ring buffers and someone else
another thread is is in charge of sort
of flushing that data to disk and and
takes however much time it it needs
right so so now we can log to our hearts
content and this is a framework that's
really easy to add things onto as we've
tested and that's really fun to work on
so even though it's so far we've done
nothing you I'm expecting that you know
many new things could come up out of
this relatively quickly now that we've
done all this sort of a garage the
laying down the foundation or all the
hard work up front
so what now for Twitter you know we have
this grand scheme of unifying all our
cash cases and and migration is about
the most scary thing for infrastructure
engineers right if you tell people you
want to migrate from a 10 year old very
stable technology to something new they
freak out so the way we do it is we just
replace all the existing caches in a
protocol compatible wave with a
different runtime this new runtime we
make sure the runtime is good and then
whatever new features or new protocol we
want to introduce we introduce
afterwards so we're only changing one
thing at a time
so people won't have to worry about oh
the new product is bad or the new
runtime has I don't know but it's bad
right so we only change one variable at
a time
and eventually we'll be able to migrate
and that would be awesome and for the
rest of you because you're not working
at Twitter so so how does this apply um
I really think there should be a much
more active community around caching
development I've I've heard people who
did really cool work
based on cash they push things to GPU
they sometimes view things poor
InfiniBand none of them can eventually
go back be merge back into sort of that
the main version because because what
they provide is sort of don't fit you
have to fork them the co-pays but if you
have a relatively modular construction
then we can viewed five different
backends we can view attend it from
executables depending on how you
configure it then depending on what you
exact feature you want so we can have
sort of a poor Tomas ISM a prolific
creation of functionalities without a
prolific ation of code bases so that's
the whole point of a having a framework
is we think we compute everything out of
a single codebase
so originally I was hoping that I could
open source the code base for this talk
but around the time I had the talk I
also became a manager and and that would
prove to be detrimental to my
productivity so so so we're we're a
little behind but you know I get help so
things are getting better so we are
gonna do the proper thing we're gonna
document everything we actually have the
binaries running just fine but we want
to do more testing and have
documentation so people can read they
don't have to dig into the wild code
word so and we want to do open source
right so I've got my name attached to a
number of token source projects I have
to admit I so far I've been doing a
terrible job sort of keeping up with the
open source community and I think a
critical part of that is when you
develop in private and push to the open
sewers you're not really doing open
source right only I think I think a
project can only take the open source
community seriously when the Vaman is
actually dying in the open so we're
gonna try that this time we're gonna
move entirely on to get up when we open
source so I want to know you know if you
have anything that that you want to be
it out of cash that has had the only
thing that has the turbulence so far as
because the unwieldy codebase I want to
hear what kind of things you may need
out of caching and
you know we have two minutes quickly
funding this type of doing everything
you've already have again type of
project is extremely hard right I had
this idea like in 2012 it's only until
last year that I actually could get the
resource to do it so so so that sort of
points to some problem about the
environment and the refactoring is a
continual process many times in the
development I'm like I finally have a
version of the module that I can be
proud of
yay and three weeks later I come back
and look at it and be like this is crap
so I had to rewrite it so so refactoring
is not gonna solve I think from this
point on it's still gonna happen like
three months later I'll be like oh this
piece is not good enough and I'm just
not changing um
and form actually does influence
functionality so so if you structure
code in particular way functionality
sort of happens within the boundaries so
if your boundaries are set incorrectly
things that are sort of smashed together
they tend to stay coupled and you cannot
change them it very easily so so the
sort of the structure of the code base
is actually much more important than
what each individual component actually
can do and you know it's nice to sort of
try to predict what's gonna happen what
technology what kind of use cases you
have but you will always be wrong a lot
of the time so so so don't take any of
those assumptions too seriously and
eventually you know it's nice to have be
working in a consistent code base if you
want long names dual names just do them
everywhere if you want your names to
show names do it everywhere if you want
to you know use a particular style
because a lot of times when you see a
code base where you just don't know
what's happening what's happening in one
go Bay in one file is very different
from what's happening another file and
you can clearly tell they're written by
different people that actually is very
bad for productivity so what we try to
enforce is everything should look more
or less the same stall wise so with that
that's the end of the talk we I think we
have one minute so if anybody wants to
ask questions ask now or you can find me